I watched some of your recent
conversation with Russell Brand and
although I agree with your perspective
of completely I don't know that it went
extraordinarily well from the standpoint
of changing the minds of his audience
for example what's your sense of this
vaccine denias
um
I suppose that is a a debate that that
we ought to be having because it is very
very widespread vaccine denies denial is
a very widespread thing and it
influences a lot of people
um there are possibilities of
presidential candidates being strong
vaccine denial so I think it is a debate
we really do need to have
um and um I'm not the best qualified to
do that but epidemiologists and doctors
um I think probably need to get out
there and have that debate